good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Wednesday it's hump day it
doesn't feel like a hump day I don't
know why but it doesn't it's dirty it
doesn't feel like a hump day for me
because I'm doing Sakara this week and
it's supposed to start on a Monday but I
started it on Sunday so it's like been
one two three days so for me every day
this week has felt like the day ahead
it's a terrible way to be next time I do
it I'm starting on a Tuesday so that
every day feels like the day behind one
thing about Jack she ain't going to
follow the rules she ain't no this this
wasn't even about breaking the rules cuz
actually one thing about me is I am
going to follow the rules like you know
it kills me to start on a Sunday when it
begins on a Monday but I'm like why not
start bettering myself the sooner the
better right TST TB but now I'm punished
because my whole week is thrown off
yesterday I thought it was Wednesday
today I think it's Thursday and that's a
horrible feeling to be terrible thinking
that like tomorrow I'm going to think
it's Friday and it's not going to be
Friday it's the most saddest existence
on the planet right so that's why next
time I'm going to start on a Tuesday
that way on Tuesday I feel like it's
Monday and then the weekend will just
sneak up on me life hack today is kind
of a major day for
me per
why don't say perro
please please perro one
R oh are they not spelled the same I
think perro dog is two
RS regardless don't use that word in my
presence okay llama
llama because today I have a ski
lesson oh my gosh I'm so excited for you
for me for the community and for the
patreon I started vlogging last night oh
my I'm so excited to watch this patreon
and I'm really curious to see how it is
you are going to an indoor ski lesson
yes so I talked about this on the
patreon a bunch but we're going skiing
next week for our family vacation and
like I want to do it like I want to do
it but I don't want to go there with
everyone and you Jack you Ben Margot
everyone knows how to ski I don't want
to like be alone on the loser Hill with
an instructor so I've decided to take
matters into my own hands and
proactively take a lesson today I have a
2-hour private lesson I I'm excited I'm
also nervous because I I'm going to have
to ask the instructor to film me for
patreon and like that will be
humiliating but listen I've committed to
this craft and these are the things I
have to do I bought a microphone too
like I am nervous are you going to put
the microphone like in your ski jacket
I'm going to clip it yeah
I love
that yeah so I am scared I'm excited I'm
nervous and I'm just like I think it's
something like I I could be good at I
don't know why like I am kind of like
limber yeah no you're not not athletic
it's not out of the cards for you to be
good at it but you're going to have to
be really patient like it's going to be
torture for a while like no your shins
are going to hurt your everything hurts
the equipment is like so uncomfortable
and you might not even love it today
because it's not like you're skiing and
the slopes of coral like it's not going
to be that amazing but you're sewing the
seeds just remember that yeah okay like
you just like maybe not excited about it
no I'm just I want to set expectations
like today's not going to be the best
day ever it's going to be hard work diry
but nothing worth having comes without
hard work should I try snowboarding no
okay just looks so much easier it's like
not I know and it's like it's not your
VI like like if I was just a girl who
like shredded Nar on her snowboard like
oh my God I'd be so chill you could
still Shred the Nar on your skis yeah
know I just want to be like Rachel
Green you'll get there so that's me
today and I'm excited I'm excited for
you please keep us posted please patreon
as much as you can and that's my viewing
experience tonight can't wait you'll see
in the Vlog I literally could not find
anyone to go with me like cuz it's in
the middle of the day and everyone I
asked was was like no ma'am I have a job
so you'll see I don't want to spoil how
it ended but I did I did find
accompaniment oh I'm excited it's not
that shocking but is it Satchel no I
asked her Margaret to come with me I
don't want to spoil the Vlog I don't
okay okay okay this is really exciting
guess I'll be watching some TV tonight
even though I've been reading at night I
don't have enough time to read but I'm
loving the book I'm reading which is me
too Elon musk's biography called Elon
Musk and I only get like 30 to minutes
to an hour read at night but like it's
like I can't put it down I want to like
keep reading right now I'm at the point
in his life where he marries his first
wife Justine throwback and everybody's
like don't do it Elon it's crazy to like
read that they're like you're going to
be miserable you're s like they were
apparently is miserable no they were a
toxic couple oh bad couple like his
mother was like you'll never know like a
day of Joy oh my God but he did it
anyway that's so Elon yeah so it's the
book is so good it's so long I've been
reading it for a few nights I'm only at
like 8% it's probably going to take me
until 20124 to finish it but I'm
thoroughly enjoying it I am reading a
fabulous Thriller that's kind of like
the Thriller of the moment you would
love it like it's so funny what what is
it it's called none of this is true by
Lisa Jewel like everyone's reading it
right now oh she's a girly I don't think
I've ever read one of her books but
they're always being recommended I don't
think I have either but I'm loving it
like I had an hour left last night and
like it was just 11: and I really wanted
to finish but between my eye twitch like
I need my sleep you have to prioritize
sleep and Ben has been you know Ben's
been having a rough time I feel like the
first couple of days post Theo like
we're very me Centric and Ben was very
strong for me but he's kind of breaking
down so reading is kind of like a
solitary activity and he needs you he
needs your companionship he needs my
full attention so I gave it to him but
everyone just send positive thoughts
Ben's way he's struggling you know he's
a strong person he's he's also a person
you know who hasn't dealt with a lot of
grief so this is all new to him yeah and
he's struggling it's hard it is hard and
you know Ben took his role as a as a dog
dad very very very seriously and it was
something he prided himself on he was an
amazing is an amazing father so he's
struggling I'll send some good vibes his
way some funny memes he's on my meme
drro list he's he's one of my favorite
people to send memes too because there
are so many memes I see that are like
this is for Ben whether it's a golf meme
inappropriate something toilet humor Ben
yeah Ben covers like a wide gamut of
dumb
humor I'm going to double down on my
meme Dish show to cheer him up that I
think would go a long way plus a sweet
text message A sweet text message yeah
from the heart on on talk to text he
would love that from the talk to text
heart so we've got a great show today
there is a story going around that I
like not to Center myself um was
freaking out like when I woke up this
morning everyone was tagging me in this
story on Tik Tok I sent it to you did
you add it to that stor why was everyone
tagging you and freaking out oh my God
what do we you have to talk about this
on the podcast what is Luke doing Luke
Luke Luke and honestly I was like I
don't even know how I could talk about
this on the podcast because I feel like
I'm missing a chunk of the story but
then Luke Holmes King immediately
responded jumped to action oh they sent
it to you before his response yeah just
the news story that it was like a local
news story that went viral about Luke
Holmes and then that elicited response
from him great so I I didn't even know
what I could say on this show because
everything that was said in that news
story went against everything I think I
know about Luke Holmes got it okay so
we'll get into it that is our first
story so without further ad Doo here are
the fast High stories that youit do need
to know and the fast five stories that
you do need to know are brought to you
by Zach do have you ever been on the
hunt for a new doctor and you ask
literally everyone you know for their
recommendation you know you're just
looking for a doctor who gets you
listens to you makes you feel super
comfortable and then after after weeks
of searching you call their office have
an appointment and then the receptionist
tells you that they don't take your
insurance so that's a horrible feeling
and Zach do is out to eliminate that
feeling so zacho is a free app where you
can find amazing doctors book
appointments online we're talking about
booking appointments with thousands of
top rated patient review doctors and
Specialists you can filter specifically
for ones who take your insurance are
located near you and treat almost any
condition you're searching for these
doctors have all have all verified
reviews from actual real patients not
robots and the average weight time to
see a doctor booked on Zach talk is just
between 48 and 20 24 and 48 hours you
can even score a same day appointment
once you find the doctor you want you
can book them immediately with just a
few app Taps no more waiting awkwardly
on hold with a receptionist and like you
can just get the information you need
like do they take your insurance do they
have availability are they far from me
is this a good doctor whether you move
like when Jackie moved I know it was
like hard to find all new everything
like doctor all new peeps everything but
even as an adult like I'm always having
like strange issues you even my eye
twitch I might have to go see an
opthalmologist like have I don't have an
opthalmologist on retainer you know it's
hard to find Specialists and like new
peeps one thing about tury and I we have
great eyesight right it's kind of like
not an us problem so Zach do is perfect
for that once you find the doctor you
want you can book them immediately go to
zach.com toast and download the Zach do
app for free then find and book a top
rated doctor today that's zocdoc.com
toast Zach do.com toast today's episode
is also brought to you by game time you
should not have to worry about when to
buy tickets for your next big event game
time is the fast and easy way to buy
tickets for all the sports music comedy
and theater near you with killer last
minute deals all in prices and views
from your seats game time takes the
guesswork out of buying tickets and of
course the game time guarantee means
you're getting the best price guaranteed
game time is the only ticketing app that
gives you complete piece of mind with
your next with your purchase see the
view from your seat before you buy so
you know exactly what to expect when you
arrive and my opinion the greatest part
about game time is the all-in pricing it
shows you your total upfront so you know
what you're getting and that you're
getting a great deal before you check
out and you can buy buy tickets in
seconds with two Taps we've all been
like scouring the internet for tickets
find something that's decently
reasonable and by the time we get to
check out it's almost double the price
because of all the fees that they don't
show you everything you see on the game
time app is all in so you will be able
to know what you're paying very simple
know what you're paying as you're paying
it game time has deals on tickets right
up to the start of the event and even an
hour after it starts you can find
exclusive Flash Deals and sponsor deals
on tickets for football football
basketball baseball concerts comedy
theater and more the game time guarantee
means you'll always get the best price
so if you find tickets in the same
section and row for Less game time will
credit you 110% of the difference so
take the guesswork out of buying tickets
with Game Time download the game time
app create an account and use code toast
for $20 off your first purchase terms
apply again create an account redeem
code t o a s for $20 off download game
time today last minute tickets lowest
price guad oned that's code to a s
today's episode is also brought to you
by seed seed's ds01 daily symbiotic is a
broadspectrum probiotic and Prebiotic
formulated with 24 clinically and
scientifically studied strains for Whole
Body Benefits including gut skin and
heart health so if you have been looking
for a morning routine that's going to
make you feel good if you're looking to
take care of your gut you're looking for
better digestion check out seed it is a
fan favorite in the ashre family Ben in
our Vlog this morning Ben was drinking
it like being like a sponsored Queen
um it's fabulous and so if you've taken
a probiotic or Prebiotic before and you
don't feel like it's had any benefits
that's probably because the the
probiotic you were taking was not
surviving your digestive tract and
that's really what sets seeds apart is
like their capsule and capsule is built
to survive your digestive system to
actually deliver the nutrients so it
can work amazing it can help you poop
every day become more regular big soft
duties your body will feel great and for
a lot of people including us it's become
a non-negotiable in our everyday
routines so you can support your gut
barrier recovery you can reinforce
healthy light Junction function in vitro
and it just is going to promote healthy
regularity and stool quality it
reinforces a healthy gut skin access to
promote clear skin for improved comfort
and
appearance so Now's the Time you know
don't wait till the new year to start
like a good morning routine visit
seed.com toast and use code toast to
redeem 25% off your first month of seeds
DS1 daily symbiotic that's seed seed.com
toast and use code toast great our first
story The aformentioned luk Holmes drama
luk Holmes has responded to the $250,000
Tumbl lawsuit against a pelis County
woman okay let me just you don't need to
read it I'll tell you so this local news
story like went a little viral and it
went viral on Tik Tok and you know
really blew up in the Illinois Community
so much so that Luke Holmes responded
and what the what the the local news
story had portrayed was a very sad story
of a woman whose full-time job is she
makes tumblers you know custom tumblers
and she went to a Luke Holmes concert
over the summer and had such a great
time that she started making Luke Holmes
tumblers and she's not you know a bil
ion Dollar business she had said that
she had made about $380 in profit from
her Luke home sales on Amazon then this
woman experienced some sort of health
issue and was in the hospital for a very
long time and when she got home she saw
in her email not only her email her junk
email like it went to spam because in
Illinois there's a new law that allows
like judgments and settlements to be
done over email which is like kind of
fock this woman didn't know she was
being sued didn't know that she lost and
found out after coming home from the
hospital via email that she owed Luke
Holmes $250 ,000 and that she even just
had found out then that she was being
sued for copyright infringement by Luke
Holmes Incorporated so Amazon froze her
account she has $5,500 in there that's
money she needs to pay her medical bills
it's money she needs to pay Luke Holmes
it was just a terrible story and really
a story that made no sense because if we
know one thing about Luke Holmes he's
not a greedy person you know he's one of
those artists who makes his tickets as
cheap as possible he doesn't do Dynamic
pricing he's always giving away free
tickets he's really not this like
capitalist King you know he makes a lot
of money and it's enough for him he
doesn't do the
most he doesn't you know milk every last
drop of money from his career like he
makes a very very good living and he's
happy with it and he does a lot for his
fans so the notion that he would a sue a
fan kind of makes no sense the notion
that he would sue someone who's really
yes technically the law wasn't on her
side she was breaking the law but the
fact that he would sue a fan who's made
so little money off his back like it
just it didn't make sense and this woman
was just very she was pathetic like she
doesn't have $250,000 she has all these
medical bills she had like heart attack
and she's a huge Luke homes fan like it
was just the whole story made absolutely
no sense so everyone's tagging me in
this this morning like literally I'm
scrolling Instagram seeing everyone tag
me and then two seconds later reactive
King Luke Holmes makes a Tik Tok and
immediately addresses it what he said
was he woke up at 500 in the morning to
go to the bathroom he's really being
very descriptive he brought his phone he
brought his phone and everyone I guess
was sending him a story he had no idea
what it was about he calls his
management he calls his attorneys and it
turns out he has one one of these
companies that basically scour the
internet for like International
corporations that make millions of
dollars selling counterfeit merch a lot
of artists do this it's never meant to
attack like a small Etsy shop or a fan
account it's for these big International
companies that make if it goes uned like
someone could just say they're the Lukes
official merch site and sell L merch and
so someone needs to be out there
pleasing that so he has a company that
does that for him he doesn't monitor it
he just knows that this company is
taking care of of these big big fake
companies but in their you know in their
work scouring the internet they they did
Sue this lady and he was like I called
the local news station asked them to put
me in contact with her I called my
attorneys and here's what he did he was
like I had no idea about this I would
never do that you guys know I love my
fans I would never sue a fan and I'm he
said I'm not a greedy person like this
isn't what I do but to rectify the
situation you know she had that $5,500
in her Amazon account that she could not
get out and that's money she needs to
live and money she needs to pay her
bills but because of the lawsuit her
account has been frozen he was like I
called her I know she needs that $5,500
I'm sending her $111,000 today that's
done that's taken care of I don't
believe he will be pursuing you know the
$250,000 that he her he's not interested
in taking money from this woman but he
also put up a tumbler for sale on his
website and all the proceeds of that
will be going to this woman who's
obviously just fallen on hard times with
her small business being frozen and then
this medical issue that she had so he's
releasing like an exclusive tumbler all
the proceeds will be going to her so
she's not going to have to pay him back
she just got $111,000 from Luke and he's
creating like a revenue stream for her
for this difficult time that she's in
like I knew it like I knew it and how he
was just and he invited her and her
family to a concert and he's just doing
the most and he was so no one was more
upset aside from the woman no one was
the second most upset about the
situation than Luke that his name was
being used and this is what was
happening to a fan of his not not on his
watch right he's not an artist who's
like notorious ly litigious he's not an
artist who's like greedy and is always
just like doing things for money I feel
like he probably could be way more like
greedy and Rich and Famous if he wanted
to be but he's just happy and content
with the amount of money he makes which
I'm sure is a lot so the story made no
sense to me and his explanation was good
enough for me I'm that's my king right
there like he rectified it he went above
and beyond it's not even like he dropped
the case like he went above and beyond
for this woman and I loved his direct
approach he didn't you know release a
written statement that took hours to
write he said I found out at 5: in the
morning it's now 7:30 I've pass spent
the last 2 hours figuring out what the
[__] is going on Direct speaking to
camera speaking to his fans it wasn't
super tailored he you know he was saying
um and like because he was just speaking
in the moment and that's how you handle
a scandal yeah this situation is
rectified but also he hadn't done
anything wrong so it's not like he was
pursuing this woman and now he needs to
backtrack like this happened outside of
his control he controlled the situation
it's rectified now she's having a great
day medical bills are paid Tumblr on the
site like something good came out of it
something good came out of it and I just
knew it like I never doubted Luke for a
second I'm like I don't think that this
is true yeah I feel like if we had
reported on the story before his
response we would be like this feels
weird like let's wait let's give him the
benefit of the doubt details yeah I
don't think we would have jumped on hash
Luke is overp party hash Luke is never
over party Luke will never be overp
party luk has never been over party like
no could never be overp party you wish
he was but he never will be overp party
Luke should never be over party Luke
shant ever be over party Luke can't ever
be over party and Luke W ever be over
party
period
cap No Cap Luke is busing okay Luke is
busing Luke is busing and that's and
that's how the cookie crumbled on the
tumbler today yeah I knew he would make
it right not only did he make it right
he went above and beyond are you going
to get a Tumblr oh sure I am like kind
of in my Tumblr era mhm because like now
I have like my new kitchen and I'm
really like me and Bennett always you
know makes his green juice in the
morning and like I have a coffee like we
have we have cups you know we're like a
cups house when we went to dve and
Busters uh last weekend for some fun in
the we won so many tickets we got two
tumblers so I have that I have like I
kind of I'm like tumbled out Stanley no
my Stanley I have my special lacroy
tumblers like I have a lot of tumblers I
feel like Trisha pis like people who
collect tumblers it's a thing that
you're one step closer to being like a
mama bear so I had this discovery on the
toilet yesterday and I think it's
incredibly profound I'm so glad I just
remembered it because I think it's
true growing up is becoming the person
you used to make fun of 100% there was
something recently that I was thinking
about doing and it's like if you ever
told me that I was going to be doing
that or maybe it was just like I forget
what maybe it was just beef stew in
general like the way I'm so passionate
about beef stew and like yeah if growing
up if you were like we're having beef
stew for dinner I'd be like yuck yeah
yuck bomb.com emancipate me now now it's
like beef Su gets me going yeah no I I
don't forget what made me have the
discovery but I think it was like I I
think I was reading like inspirational
quotes and they really kind of moved me
and I was thinking about maybe even
posting one and I realized like I have
fully become a person I used to make fun
of like even I have this crazy memory
and it's just such a testament to how
immature I was I remember watching the
real houses of Atlanta like a million
years ago and Kenya Moore's dog had
passed away like very tragically very
suddenly and she was like balling with
the other woman and I I was like this
woman is not okay like she was acting
like seriously like like a person died
and she was just in like inconsolable
and I remember thinking like this is
insane and that's me now like I cry
three times a day like I I am the person
I used to make fun of yeah but that's
growth but I also I feel like there are
so many things that are like cliche
things but then for a reason like I feel
like for mamas it's like you know the
claw clip the Tumblr and it's like no we
don't just like go and seek those things
out because you feel like you're
supposed to have them it's like no I
need to just get my hair up really quick
like I literally was I was driving and I
had like my claw clip my tumber like I
was in like Mama mode but it it just it
happened to me I did not seek it out I'm
so glad you brought that up as well
because let's talk about driving in a
clock clip and how unbelievably annoying
it is no even driving in an updo bun
like I have to take my hair down and
it's it's like it I just styled it and
put it up but I can't it's a hazard it's
a hazard I was I can't look to the left
and the right my I need like a
a seat that has a little hole
indentation for my bun and what like
yeah unless I can get my bun high enough
but that's not the kind of bun I want to
be wearing I feel you it's really
annoying that's how you get a headache
yeah or you just have to sit like ram
rod straight and then your bun is just
like touch it it's it's quite
uncomfortable I'm so glad we're talking
about this it's not an updo friendly
activity and that is hard for me cuz I
love an updo I know I'm even wearing a
claw clip right now wouldn't be able to
drive but you're right like things are
cliche for a reason and I think part of
growing up is realizing like the
cringiness that you used to feel from
cliches when you get older it's just
like no it's more of an understanding
yeah and then it becomes comforting it's
like I'm just part of the system you
know I'm like everyone else I'm just a
human I'm just ordinary
girl sometimes I'm lazy I get bored I
feel scared I feel
ignored do I sound amazing I feel happy
I get silly I choke on my own words
there was one other like Mama thing I
was doing recently where I was having
like a a mama Epiphany I was seeing
myself from above like this is who she
is now no you know what it was I posted
yesterday I've been getting all these
targeted videos my algorithm is
targeting me for like homesteading
videos do you know what that is I saw
you post about this but I don't know
what homesteading is so I don't know
exactly what it is but it's pretty much
like people who make their own
everything like they grow their own food
they have their chickens they have their
own eggs like everything in their they
don't have to go to the grocery store
they are it's a lifestyle of
self-sufficiency say self-sufficient by
substenance agriculture home
preservation of food and may also
involve the small scale production of
textiles clothing and craft work for
household use or sale textiles like well
I make my own merch oh my God you are
homesteading but yeah no like and I
think I think the first fora into
homesteading like the Gateway is a
sourdough starter oh my God that's so
factual have you seen these no but I
know that like souro starter is a
gateway drug to like a different life a
different living off the grid yeah so I
feel like I haven't been pulled and it's
like I don't have use sourdough every
day but now I'm like thinking back to
like when you got me all those sourdough
from Eli's and apparently like if you
make your own sourdough it's the best
best I don't know maybe it's cuz I live
in New York and I'm blessed and
privileged to live amongst the most the
finest bakeries French bakeries you know
I don't see a need to do what other
people are doing so well you can't
Homestead in New York you like don't
even have the space to do it and
everything is about convenience so it's
not the place to do it but in this video
that I posted yesterday it's like all
these modern conveniences that we think
are like oh my God can't live without
like they're making us sick and sad
Jackie do you know what you need I could
see you doing this even though it's like
a little unsanitary so that's the only
reason compost no that's disgusting I
could see you like getting chickens and
like having your own eggs I would love
there's nothing better than farm fresh
eggs but like do you think your HOA
would be okay with that no right no I
don't but I would love to not have
chickens cuz I'm I'm scared of animals
except for breu and do and
meoo but I like there there is a serious
difference between a just hatched egg
and a store-bought egg yes so when we go
to Brian's house Brian kind of
homesteads like he has chickens and all
the eggs in his entire place are from
his farm obviously and he like gives
them away to everyone because there's
like so many chickens and so many and
they're enormous they're like green
they're not even like brown or white
like they're a crazy they not supposed
to be white right and they're they're
definitely different they're like
natural yeah no it's just so tasty ier
richer and I just my my last question is
like how are you supposed to Homestead
when you like have children cuz it's
like I barely have time to make
meatballs like how am I pickling my food
storing it making my own jams and
turning my own butter I think a better
question is how are you supposed to
Homestead if you have a job like
homesteading sounds like a full like if
you committed your entire day not like
you let's say right now I'd be
homesteading instead of podcasting yeah
like no podcasting like you wouldn't be
able to raise children and home
Homestead like it's impossible no I
think like people who raise children
they they Homestead and they're driven
to it because they want to give their
children like really great things but I
think also eventually the children help
in the homesteading like they're with
the chickens they're you know over the
butter yeah they're making their own
candles for and then they sell them at
local fairs and that's how you sustain
because you you're spending all your
time homesteading you need to make a
living I assume that the husband is out
working we should hope we would hope um
you did just remind me though about
animals that I've started the process of
looking for a new puppy of looking for
Shell of looking for Sheldon and the end
of the year is hard cuz so many people
get dogs for Christmas and I'm like late
so it probably will take some time
however I did chat with um someone who
might have a litter coming up for me and
she was sending me pictures of the
lineage you know the mother and the
father and you know background Health
genetics things I'm I'm very I'm going
to be much more specific this time
around about what sort of Health
screenings need to be done and I took it
as a side because they sent me a picture
of the parents and these parents were
gorgeous gorgeous Cavaliers and the
mother her name was Jackie and I just
think that's crazy was she a homesteader
she was gorgeous she was like a
nine-time national show dog Champion
like she was a queen she was actually
like a huge Queen in Quebec the queen of
Quebec yeah okay I think it's a good
sign I'm going to say something really
crazy that you're going to shut me me
down for but I just you know there's no
such thing as a bad idea that's not
that's actually not a saying but um I'm
it is today I love the idea is
Marketplace take it or leave it okay say
it oh my God there is a pet store no oh
my God
near in our neighborhood where like the
last time I walked by it had the cutest
Blom Cavalier not saying that Cavalier
is still there but like maybe they have
Cavs no it I like I will be getting a
dog from a breeder and I know like I
like on the level of acceptable
acceptable ways socially acceptable ways
to get a dog it goes adopt breeder pet
store like I would never go to a pet
store and I know it's said cuz like
those dogs the dogs are alive already
it's like someone should help them but
part but then you're perpetuating the
business of pet stores I understand but
also like pet stores are notorious for
selling you know sick inbred dogs and
that's something I just experienced and
that's why I'm like being really
particular about the breeder that I go
through that I understand and what sort
of like genetic testing and background
and health screenings that they do so
it's so not an option for me even though
like of course it breaks my heart to
walk past a pet store I'm a human
especially if there's like a cute Blum I
know I know okay and and by the way I
know that pet stores are bad please like
don't send me videos like I'm I'm aware
like adopt don't chop do strong okay
please like don't put that on me today
I'm not in the mood to sift through my
DM with like sad
videos guys Mama's get her mostly
because like I know and you should adapt
and don't shop and that was only like an
idea for Claudia that wasn't for
everyone okay well I'm not doing it you
should adopt and don't chop so back to
Luke Holmes it should really be adopt
don't
shop oh or adop don't
shop the slogan needs some Mark the tea
is just
errant adopt don't
chop
yeah that's better yeah are you ready
for our next story mhm it's someone's
birthday today it is taylored Swift is
all smiles as she brings in her 34th
birthday with Miles Teller and his wife
Kelly Sperry as they leave a restaurant
in the we hours so tailored went out
last night to ring in her birthday they
went to parcel Kenneth parcel restaurant
in New York they went to ra
parcel ra parcel greater than Kenneth
parcel oh it's tough but yeah rage has
to go to parcel yeah I didn't even by
the way I like to pride myself on being
you know somewhat in the know yeah never
heard of this place you've got to go to
parcel I've never heard of this place
but it's like maybe it's
parelli that does sound right it's p a
it's p a r c e l l e that's
parcel but that extra e parel
parcel parcel so they went to parcel
last night and Selena was there at 1.2
they left at 12:22 a.m. officially
ringing in Miss Taylor's birthday at
Parelli's and looks like a great time
was had by all Squad gold Trav wasn't
there Trav was not there but the rumor
mill is that Travis is planning her a
birthday party in New York City no
expense spared nothing is too good for
his girl and that should be happening
tonight or maybe this week again well
what's Travis's schedule this
week Chief's schedule okay cuz as a
football player like can you just do
whatever you want during the week
between games like no you have practice
no okay so his next game is December
17th at 1:00 p.m. I think that's
Saturday yeah that's on Saturday that's
on
Sunday where is it at the Patriots New
England oh so he no town I don't think
they get to the town till like
Friday well they have to all stay in the
same Hotel Saturday night okay either
the party is tonight like with enough
days before the game or it's Sunday
night after the game rain or shine
wouldn't he have to be in Kansas City
for practice that's what I'm
saying maybe
they yeah well maybe he's like jetting
in jetting out I don't know this was
also a topic of discussion cuz when they
had their by week and he went to
Argentina like some Talking Heads were
upset that like that's how he he was
like you know
jettisoning around the world and he
should be like with the team like head
down but I don't know if you're like
doing well and you're winning games then
do whatever the [__] you want is my
policy well at that point he was doing
well in winning gam so he can do
whatever the [__] he wants but in the
last week they won like this week it
might be a hard week for him to just
like go and celebrate his girl's
birthday I know like he might have a
hard time getting the T too
because they need him they and they need
to practice as a team
right team whatever they'll make it work
I I just do have a lot of questions
about like the the schedule and I feel
like we've have so many wag listeners
drop a comment like what are you allowed
to do during the week when you have a
game like if you're traveling when do
you leave do you have practice how many
days you get a day off I think also when
they played the Jets he stayed at her
apartment but that was like kind of not
Kosher also it's not like I know for a
fact that you have to stay even when you
have a home game you have to stay in a
hotel with your brother's teammates the
night before a game yeah but he chose
his
girl no and him like throwing her no
expense spared party like it's just it's
like a it's a movie it's a book I feel
like no one's ever thrown her a party
before I know it's like she has
everything in the world but like no
one's ever thrown her a birthday like
she's probably she's always thrown for
herself you know we always do those
photo booth picks and it must be nice to
have someone just throw you a party yeah
and somebody like with money you know
means yeah yeah yeah not like I think a
lot of celebrities like have people
throw them parties but they end up
paying for the party oh my friends threw
this for me they planned it but I paid
for it yeah yeah yeah no not that no
like somebody fully picking up the bill
and this is just Why this relationship
is so different for tailored on on every
level yeah where do you think the part's
going to be I have to like literally
sneak in zero Bond yeah I think so too
I'm on my way I'm on my way
that's my favorite
quote what's it from you it's from I've
never even seen this show I saw a clip
of it once Super Nanny remember that
British lady who would like go to the
homes of like troubled kids and whip
their asses into shape and so every
episode starts she's like in the back of
this old school British Town Car and
she's like reading the file and she's
like I'm on my way is that the one with
the kid who's like she's a queen and
we're the sorry people
yes classic stuff
yes I guess we don't don't even realize
the level of influence super nanny has
on us like all this time we never even
put that together I didn't even know
that was the name of the show it was an
amazing show and kids have been acting
out ever since yeah it's not a
coincidence no the nanny's been really
quiet and the nanny's been really quiet
that's how she became the
nanny are you ready for our next Story
number three number three yeah don't
you're get a TST you're good you're good
um a little more like semi- relationship
news question mark because Glenn Powell
and Sydney Sweeney are out promoting
their movie and you know doing the most
together so Gwen Powell jokes that
Sydney Sweeney is the only person who's
seen all of his body after this anyone
scene from their new movie anyone but
you where he um had a nude scene I guess
he like took his pants off too quick on
a cliff but these two are like joking
around their press tour together like
yeah like it's I feel like At
first I believed it mhm and now like
they're playing into it too much and a
lot of people I forget where I saw this
I feel like maybe it was not skinny not
Fat's Instagram Sydney Sweeney's fiance
is a producer of this movie like it's
this clearly what's going on is is for
press and I need people to be like a
little bit more smart here okay like use
critical thinking so she's still with
her fiance this is what pisses me off
actually okay people on the internet are
so dumb like Taylor Swift is in a
full-blown relationship this is PR but
Sydney Sweeney and Glen POA like who are
so clearly both not in a relationship
but like are promoting a movie together
about like two people who have chemistry
like it's so clearly PR everyone's like
I'm obsessed I stand but like when other
people have relationships that are so
clearly like real everyone's like oh
this is PR Chris Jenner RS hard but the
devil Works harder shut
up like people are so
stupid
yeah that's about it that's that on that
like these two are not dating they have
are not but I feel like I feel like they
they gave it a shot like if there was
any chemistry between them they would be
dating but now we can rule out that
there isn't because like it would be
more convenient for everyone if they
just dated the thing is like I don't
think so like for real like I think
they're both like hardcore professional
actors like they did a movie together
like so yes they both happen to be
good-looking but like she's in a
relationship he was for a very long time
like I don't know just because they're
both good-looking like in a movie where
they kiss like I don't know I just don't
think I don't know I don't think they'd
be a good couple you don't
no I don't to know Glen Powell I think
they would be a good couple like if they
were both on the list we would put them
together so I'm glad like I'm glad that
I can I'm glad that I can like live
knowing that like they're not suited for
one another because if they were they
would have Fall in Love on the set of
this movie I don't think you heard
me we just kind of skipped over
something I said that you know Gwen
Powell I do know Gwen
Powell I just felt like I wanted to say
that do you have any followup questions
about me knowing Glen pal no cuz I
believe we've been over this oh have we
Glenn and I are actually really I'm sure
I'm sure but no like Glen Glen pal is
one of our favorite young actors mhm and
she's a favorite young actress
yeah
therefore like the thing is I just like
I'm smarter than this you know these two
are not dating well I mean I don't think
they're like so me with Taylor and
Travis like screaming at everyone oh my
God totally oh my God don't listen to me
what do I know we'll check back in when
the movie's done you know yeah I'm not
giving this my heart and soul yet but
they're also like not really they're not
saying that they're dating they're just
like wanting you to think it yeah which
is always it's like you know loow
hanging fruit of movie PR sure right
right right but when it works like when
it's real oh my God there's nothing
better there's nothing
actually
more effective in terms of marketing
than two people who are actually in love
and don't get us started on this whole
High School Musical Twilight
conversation but you guys know what
we're talking about I'll just give you
one more reference just to like bring
the point home Mr Miss
Smith yeah
it's that's kind of the
blueprint yeah and this is not that no
this is not that and the movie
looks
it looks cute it looks like a smut novel
come to life yeah it's just very like
unserious and random yeah it better be
good yeah is it I think it's in theaters
It Feels Like A streamy vibe yeah I
think Maestro is a streamy Vibe I just
saw the premiere was last night and it
said Netflix on the steeping repeat
really I thought that was like a theater
oscar but it's Ste movie that felt like
a real movie yes being distributed by
Netflix and it's Steven Spielberg Martin
scorey they're lit are you sure yeah I'm
looking at it director Bradley Cooper
producers Bradley Cooper and Martin
scorey Stephen Spielberg is not a part
of this not in any way that would be in
the Marquee here I mean the way that
stepen Spielberg and Martin Scorsese are
two separate people is something that
just feels illogical to me no to me I
can keep them apart because Martin
scorey is shudder Island but he's also
very distinct looking Martin scores like
with the big eyebrows the glasses he's
like short I'm glad that I think Shuter
Island was like my first scors sty for a
because he'll always just be like crazy
scorey oh that's so funny and to me
Stephen Spielberg is
like you know epic dramas comma like
weird Gamer
movies what movie are you referring to
that one that came out recently gamer
yeah it's like gaming
H what let me just pull up the IMDb Oh e
that's not what I was talking about oh
that's
Spielberg yes that's
Spielberg oh like he does like Indiana
oh he executive producer that's not the
same as
producer Ready Player one is yeah Ready
Player one that's the one I'm talking
about the thing is I'm not a film buff
in case you couldn't
tell yeah my favorite director probably
Jud appal you know yeah mine's probably
Kenny Ortega oh
definitely also in kenan's book he
talked a lot about Jed appau because
like one of Keenan Keenan's like big
break was D3 or D2 Mighty Ducks or
whatever right but I was waiting for him
to talk about heavy weights which he did
and it was actually really interesting
because he um like he was pretty you
know overweight for most of his career
but he was like it was such a value ad
for me and I realized like how lucky I
was like nobody ever once in my career I
never went to a meeting and a director
was like you need to lose weight like it
was just I got rolls because I was fat
like heavyweights and it didn't really
Dawn on him till he got a little bit
older that like he should feel like any
sort of shame or like he just he was
very like body positive in a way that's
not what he said but he was and he got
rolls because of it and made him stand
out but it also made him look so young
which is why he was turned down for SNL
so many times because they just thought
of him as like a child actor but he was
on all that when he was 21 like he
wasn't a child wow yeah um but he talked
a lot about J appat and how that movie
like changes life but that movie could
never be made today heavyweights yeah no
heavy weighs is such a good movie it is
lunch has been cancelled due to lack of
hustle speaking of what are you having
for lunch I don't know I got to eat
something really like protein based to
get me all jacked up for my ski lesson
or you need carbs for the energy oh yeah
do I to a carbo like what do you do
before I don't know like what do you do
before just have a normal uh tury worm
Bowl should cut it that's carbs Protein
that's why we love a warm bowl it's got
it all are you ready for our next story
if it's our next story story that's
brought to you by State Farm the State
Farm personal price plan helps you
create an affordable price just for you
the plan is all about being personal to
you and your needs that means you get
the coverage you want a policy that
helps cover what's important to you and
an affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences think
about it like this from your go-to
coffee order to your favorite pair of
sweatpants we know that you love to
personalize your entire day just like we
do I mean don't get me started on how
different we are from first thing in the
morning you know I have just like a
couple of nuts for breakfast Jackie has
a couple of breakfast tacos from a place
next door she loves them and they're
really big um but so many things about
life are personal you know comedy
poetry what else do we say
food clearly personalization just makes
everything that much better and stay
State Farm believes that insurance
should work the same way your plan your
coverage your selections can all be
personalized by you because your life is
personal like Jackie she's a full life
she's a homeowner she lives in a
different state she's got dependence she
might be a homesteader she could be
starting a business from her house soon
I am a renter I live in New York City
nobody depends on me for anything so
like all that to say not that my life is
sad it's just
different we have different insurance
needs as well so like a good neighbor
State Farm is there prices vary by state
options selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary
like a good
NE St is
there today's episode is also brought to
you by vegamore we are always trying to
do right by our bodies so when it comes
to our hair and scalp Health finding a
product that actually works but is also
made with clean ingredients does always
feel like a trade-off but with vegamore
we're getting products that are made
with clean ingredients and they actually
work and they give us visibly healthy
hair and scalp so we are able to have
visibly thicker fuller shinier longer
hair without the harsh ingredients with
vegamore every cute little pink bottle
of vegamore products are 100%
crueltyfree And they are never
formulated with potentially harmful
chemicals like parabens or hormones so I
turned to vegamore Jackie and I both
found vegamore for different reasons
Jackie in her like pregnancy era was
just more conscious about clean Beauty
and so she started using the grow
shampoo and conditioner from vegamore
for me my uh hair started to fall out
when I started losing weight and I took
to the internet for recommendations and
everybody recommended the gross serum
from vegamore it was just an added bonus
for me that it was clean beauty company
for me I was really just looking for
something that worked and that was Vore
so their value kits like the grow
Essentials kit which is what we just
talked about is where you get to try
more than one amazing product at Great
savings when you sign up for a monthly
subscription you save more and you never
run low on the products that you need to
take care of your hair the key to your
hair routine is consistency for your
most beautiful healthy looking hair so
we use the vegamore grow hair serum
daily and I really like it because you
can put the serum in your hair and you
don't have to wash it like it won't
leave your hair looking oily I'm on like
day three of a wash and I used the serum
like I used it last night you don't need
to wash your hair so give your hair the
power of that little pink bottle with
vegamore for limited time toast
listeners can get 20% off their first
order by going to vore.com toast and use
code toast to check out that's v g m o
r.com toast code toast to save 20% off
your first order v g m o r.com toast Cod
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by Quint we loved gift giving but it
can really add up especially this time
of year so that's why this holiday
season we are shopping at Quin our go-to
place for luxury Essentials at an
affordable price for everyone on our
list including me Quin is probably my
favorite brand that I've discovered
because they're a sponsored like I
hadn't heard of them before and I was
honestly like now so many things in my
wardrobe are from Quints and I always
recommend Quints to people if they're
looking to like have good investment
pieces in their closet that are still
affordable so Quin offers a range of
high quality items with prices Within
Reach so they have 100% Mongolian
Kashmir sweater starting at just $50
they have washable silk tops and dresses
cotton sweaters comfortable panss the
best part is that all of Quin quin's
items are priced 50 to 80% less than
similar Brands so you're getting that
quality but you're also getting a much
more reasonable price so that's why
we're giving the gift of quin's buttery
soft cashmere to our nearest and dearest
this year they partner directly with top
factories so they can cut the cost of
the middleman and pass the savings on to
us they only wor work with factories
that use safe ethical and responsible
manufacturing practices they have
premium fabrics and finishes I love my
Kashmir sweaters I have a great pair of
like black slacks they're just like a
staple piece they're all really simple
but they're really good you We Them many
many times I've had some of their pieces
now for over a year they wear really
well they're fabulous so get affordable
luxury for everyone on your list with
Quin go to quinn.com toast for free
shipping on your order and 365 day
returns that's qu
nc.com toast to get free shipping and
365 day returns quince. comom toast
great thank you yeah well our next story
is a very long Saga that we have not
discussed on the toast but I'm sure that
you seen okay like all this stuff with
Matt R oh you know what I was going to
send you this story I know it all I
actually I know a lot of it because um
some of my friends are big Matt R fans
and they were explaining the drama to me
I had never heard of him he's this
comedian he had been he's been like
having a rough couple of weeks because
it's actually really interesting like
the come the coming up of Matt R so Matt
R was just like a a comic who did stand
up in you know clubs and stuff and he
started he just really used social media
to his advantage and he started posting
a lot of his crowd work yeah on social
media so he would have funny
interactions with people who would be
like you suck or like people who just
shout like hecklers crowd work is like a
very Niche thing on Tik Tok that people
love and he blew up so much show to the
point where he got a $25 million deal
with Live Nation to produce his tour
he's on this big arena tour he got a
Netflix special and he's pretty much
like new on the scene and his success
and his fans and his Fame comes from Tik
Tok and it's all women because he's you
know a young handsome man he's very
handsome especially like for a comedian
so right excuse me you're handsome too
thank you um so he has this really like
powerful internet fan base of women
which you know can be a scary thing if
if it goes the wrong way so first what
happened is that he released his Netflix
special it was kind of this
unprecedented thing you know people work
for years and don't get Netflix specials
and he got this Netflix special and he
had become known for his crowd work and
you really can only do crowd work in
small um clubs you know you can't do
crowd work in a theater and you really
don't do crowd work in a Netflix special
Netflix special is just more traditional
standup so he got a lot of you know
response feedback from his Netflix
special one about a particular joke he
had make about made about domestic
violence he basically was saying that
you know there was a woman who uh a
waitress of his she had a black eye and
you know maybe she wouldn't have a black
eye if she got back in the kitchen it
was like kind of a crazy joke especially
when your audience like is women like
that's who made you famous it's not like
you're doing like bro comedy like the
people who come to your show are the
girlies the girlies come to your show
Millennial women so it was kind of like
a crazy joke and there was a lot of
immediate backlash once the Netflix
special came out and he responded to it
he posted on his Instagram being like I
know a lot of people are upset about the
joke that I made so like swipe up for my
you know response and his he swiped up
to a Amazon link of like a helmet like
for kids like like get like tough get a
helmet kind of yeah yeah yeah exactly
but I do think it was also like helmets
for you know the helmets that babies
wear when they they have like a their
head is a little mhap a lot yeah like a
lot of babies wear them so it was like I
don't I didn't really understand it
honestly so it was like hell but I think
like reshape your head yeah the general
gist was life is tough get a helmet like
it's a joke get over it and so there's
just kind of been this like discourse
now on Tik Tok because Tik Tok invented
Matt Bri and what Tik Tok giveth Tik Tok
also taketh away so then people were
just dragging him saying you know his
special isn't even funny he's really
just like a crowdwork comedian he
doesn't write good jokes so another clip
of from his special went viral talking
about girls who are obsessed it was just
like the whole special was like
attacking women well yeah that's what I
heard from my friends who like really
like loved him and and every they went
to see his show and the whole audiences
women and it felt like he doesn't want
that sort of audience like he wants a
male audience so he's like offending the
people who actually come to his show
while trying to woo in people who don't
like him know him or care about him and
it's like well now you got no one so he
was just pissing everyone off and then
the comedy special that like you know
more people could see than the people
who went to his show just became clear
that like he is not interested in his
existing audience he doesn't really care
about like cultivating that fan base and
he wants like a cooler broer audience so
those are the jokes that he's making
which is so dumb because everybody knows
like if you want to be successful like
having female like women having women
with disposable income being your target
demo it's like the best like women are
more likely to buy more likely to share
more likely to attend like it's just
dumb but yes it's very clear like he
showed up and was like I want to be more
uh like who's a comic I can even compare
that has like broy audience Andrew
Schultz yeah yeah yeah exactly and he
wanted to like push the envelope and be
a little
daring so another clip of his special
goes viral and he's talking about girls
who are obsessed with like Saturn and
yeah this is what he astrology this is
the quote he said just because Jupiter
has he said he bashes women who use
astrology as an explainer for their
quote poor decision-making skills he
said just because Jupiter has a ring and
you don't doesn't mean blah blah blah so
I actually like the joke about um just
like using astrology to be an [__]
like that's actually that's a funny joke
um but people were were very quick to
point out you know Jupiter actually
doesn't have a ring it's Saturn whatever
so this other Tik Tok Creator right so
that's the story of today there's a TI
so the story of today is he's found
himself in like another drama but this
time with a child with a six-year-old
because a Tik Tok star named Bunny
hagaya uh posted a video of her son
responding to this clip so I've seen
Bunny's content before and I know that
she has a son who's he's kind of like a
seant he's very very smart like young
chelin yes and he's obsessed with
astrology the Stars so he knows
everything about the planets so he had
made a little Stitch video responding to
that Jupiter has rings with the actual
facts of the space time right he said
actually it's Saturn that has rings and
it has more also and mean to girls was
what he said so then R Matt R clapped
back in the comments writing Jupiter
also has a ring and Santa Claus isn't
real he continued saying your mom buys
you presents with the money she makes on
only fans good luck after seeing the
messages to her son then the bunny hadah
shared a Tik Tok video in which she says
while you clearly took a light-hearted
video and turned it into fighting with a
six-year-old let's talk about the
comments you said about me I have never
made a single dollar from a man you
can't accept the fact that people may
like women for their personalities
though we know you don't have one you
stick to circle jerking the men that you
need validation from and I will gladly
take your female audience that you so
desperately want to get rid of yeah okay
so I'm not generally a fan of like
putting your kid in content to like go
viral so like that part of it like did
give me like a little bit of an ick but
it was really Harless like he I I happen
to know just like from seeing her on my
fre you page like her kid is very smart
so she was just it was it was it was it
was tongue and cheek it was harmless I
don't think she thought mad R would
respond and she certainly didn't think
he would respond in such a [__] evil
way yeah um and I just is like what is
going on with Matt R like he's imploding
yeah he's imploding and he's been given
like an opportunity that literally
nobody gets like to blow up in the way
that you blow it up and have like this
old school traditional comedy support
support from you know Live Nation
Netflix like it's so unbelievable it
would never happen to a woman like it's
really it's unprecedented and for him to
just kind of be like taking a big dump
on it it feels and I'm not even like so
I'm not offended by the jokes like they
they weren't super funny but like I
would I make a joke about domestic
violence like no I wouldn't but you know
I believe in the right to make jokes
about stuff that or whatever but I just
don't know why I don't think it was like
a good you know business move for him
when his audience are women and probably
a lot of them who have been had brushes
with domestic violence so it just felt
like a bold weird choice
and you're right it's like he really
wanted to come out of this whole thing
as like bad boy Dave Chappelle like I
don't give a [__] bro like jokes for
life like yeah but also I think if you
want to
make borderline you know offensive jokes
talk about sensitive subject matter like
they have to be really funny they have
to be undeniably funny yes and and this
doesn't sound like it was that that's
actually the perfect way of putting it
um so yeah I I don't know you know in
the same breath that I heard about I had
not heard of him as I am not on Tik Tok
um it's just you know that was quick
easy come easy go I guess yeah but the
thing is is like he got that $25 million
Live Nation deal and the way that those
deals work is that you have to tour with
Live Nation until you make them back the
$25 million um and so things like this
happening where women are not going to
want to come to your shows anymore like
he might be working for Live Nation for
the rest of his life interest or maybe
all of this controversy drums up more
interest in his show I hadn't heard of
him that's true not that I'm now going
to buy a ticket but you know they do say
all press is good press yeah I just
think it was such an aggressive clap
back to a kid and it really was a
harmless video yeah yeah it's like just
save your energy like clap back at
someone else yeah like someone your own
size yeah it was weird it's very strange
behavior and you kind of putting it is
like him rejecting the audience that got
him to that's exactly what it is he
wants like dudes yeah to come to his
shows who cares yeah a ticket is a
ticket a ticket is a ticket and like if
you actually looked into like the
business of social media you would know
that like if you have an audience of
women and the same exact size like let's
say you have an audience of 100 women
and 100 men you're more likely to be
successful touring selling books women
are just like more passionate they're
you know they buy more they share more
they bring you know men just watch your
thing and move on and like burp and yeah
yeah no but I such a weird coincidence
yeah it's a weird thing but I mean maybe
that's maybe it's like if he had spent
years building up his audience and he
knew how hard it is to like you know
outside of the Tik Tok algorithm like
every fan like how hard it is to acquire
every single fan like he wouldn't be so
capricious
about saying like bye to them that's
true easy come easy go you're right
that's a very good point as well it's
the capriciousness really for me at the
end of the day it comes down to the
capriciousness cap No Cap no
cap cap bused cap on the No
Cap are you ready for our fifth and
final story mhm a little mama news
because Hillary Duff is pregnant with
her fourth child her third with her
husband Matthew coma this was a shock to
me I didn't realize like Hillary Duff
has such a brood and oh yeah I'm quite
impressed the lizie McGuire Alum and
Matthew Koma are expecting their third
child together her fourth she announced
her pregnancy on Tuesday by sharing her
family's holiday card on Instagram
saying so much for silent nights while
cradling her baby bump LS so cute so
cute um I love this queen like I love
Hillary Duff like really is kind of a
woman who does it all like she has four
kids she's been working since she was 10
and she stays relevant she stays like on
good projects like she's always just
doing good [__] even though her last
show got canceled like people loved it
yeah she stays working she stays humble
yeah she seems like have you ever seen
that video of her like attacking a
photographer for like not leaving her
kids alone she's like a protective Mama
Bear she's a mama bear yeah she's at
like a soccer game and they just don't
leave her alone and she just goes up to
them and it's like you guys are freaks
get away I could see her saying that
yeah she was like you've been following
us around all day like I'm literally at
a soccer game [__] off queen queen yeah
no I'm really happy for her and what's
the joke we have about Matthew coma so
it's a verb he's a verb when you get
Matthew coma and I guess that's like
when someone your collaborator like
takes all the credit for the work even
though you're the man behind the scenes
No not a scandal it was just like a a
public beef with zed he was like Zed's
producer for so long and and I think a
big part of Zed's success and the work
that they did together but Zed got all
the credit and he was kind of like coma
out of it that's how I remember he got
com sad I think I mean well at least he
has a full home life yeah correct me in
the comments if I missed a piece of that
or maybe he that sounds right was he
villainous I I I don't remember honestly
got cut out you're right yeah so those
were the fast five stories today is
usually the day where we do do deer
toasters we've decided to push out to
tomorrow's show because today is a nice
long juicy episode we'll let you enjoy
and I have to go ski and Jackie has a
lot of things so yeah we will do dear
toasters tomorrow and that's our show
anything you want to say to the peeps
before we let them go no Enjoy the show
we have two more shows till holiday
break just counting down tomorrow is our
second to last show so you might as you
should enjoy these Savor them Savor
maybe listen to them on half speed I was
just thinking that double the length
you'll have two hour episode today cuz
we're at an hour now yeah huh okay well
you just finished the episode so so
maybe for tomorrow yeah yeah we didn't
we should have given that advice at the
top of the show thank you guys so much
for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
[__] and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
Spotify iTunes Stitcher public radio IH
have radio castbox all the places
wherever you listen to podcast find us
the toast and leave a five star review
about about our beautiful stunning and
wickedly talented we are hope you guys
have an amazing hump day we will see you
tomorrow bye love you
bye